[Music]
hello everyone
I hope you've had a great google knack
so far and thank you so much for
attending this session
my name is Malika al-karim I'm a media
specialized customer engineer from
Google cloud and today I have the
pleasure to co-present this session with
two industry experts Jeff Bob a
principal solution design architecture
from Skype and more McCauley he's a
director of product from harmonic okay
so what are we hearing in this session
well I think it's useful for all of us
to go a little bit back and look at
what's happened in the industry how
things have shifted and changed until
we've got to this point and go to 2018
and 2019 and see what Google cloud has
done for media customers to help them
achieve their targets and implement
their interesting projects and then I'll
ask Jeff to come up the stage and take
us to their interesting journey of
designing and deploying a future-proof
sports the streaming platform and then
more is going to give us a different
angle of how they implement it they're
basically stream processing applications
on top of containers to health sky in
this wonderful project so this is really
interesting for all of us today we're
all so used to get any sort of content
with great quality on any device you
know in a way that we all forget that
this industry is actually not that old
if you look at 2005 when for the first
time YouTube was launched as basically
the biggest distributing platform in the
world ten years down the line things
shifted and changed in every different
way streaming protocols transcoding
formats infrastructure grew big data
everything changed so rapidly that 10
years down the line we see
a 4% fall from the traditional TV
viewership and that figure lent itself
into a 74 percent increase in content
viewership on YouTube so this figure
looks a little bit odd because 4% vs.
74% part of it is because the overall
viewership of content on traditional TV
was a huge number so when you lent it
into YouTube it becomes a really big
factor but the other part was that
people overall started to watch content
a lot more than they used to do before
because obviously you could find any
sort of niche content you wouldn't be
able to find on TV on YouTube three
years later this is interesting the the
overall viewership of content on
streaming platforms not only YouTube but
everywhere witnessed a 35% increase
year-on-year and then today where we're
standing people are consuming 1 billion
hours of content only on YouTube that's
a massive number so that makes us
hopeful that for the next 5 years the
the profit that gets shifted away from
traditional you know TV platforms IP TV
cable TV and this 30 billion profit will
be spent on online TV platforms so that
will take us to 2025 where half of the
viewers of the age of below 32 will
never actually see a subscription on
traditional TV platforms and that will
take the consumption of media on an
Internet to 25% of the world data
alright so we know that things have
changed so much we're really proud to be
standing in this moment but we want to
see if cloud is going to be the next big
wave of disruption in into the media and
tech industry at the same time so let's
see why cloud matters in this industry
so problem number one of every
technology company is a speed to
delivery if you're a media company your
problem is a lot bigger why you are
acquiring a lot of
from studios from sports organizations
this massive amount of money you're
spending
and you want to make sure that you're
launching the service right on time you
are actually providing any sort of
necessary infrastructure without having
to worry about infrastructure planning
and the other problem about media
industry is that it's not only about
applications it's also about the
delivery of media across the world so
you need to make sure that your content
gets and Gotha transcoded is being sent
across the world with minimum delay the
other problem is that when you work in a
really fast environment you need to be
sure that you're scaling but you're not
constantly calculating and you're not
being stingy with your infrastructure
because you want to make sure your users
are not kind of getting delays or that
you wouldn't lose your viewers to your
competition that's the a very good
example of that is news content so if
you lose one or two minutes of kind of
viewership on a kind of delivery on your
network then people would just go to
your competition and then you're using
millions of dollars of ads for something
pretty plain and simple
so with cloud you can actually do this
as scalability pretty fast and then I
just shut down your instances and after
that you don't really have to worry
about a bunch of annoying servers in
your infrastructure then again you can
have any sort of analytics you wants you
can't think about what do you want to do
with it later you can be super generous
with your with your data and you can
also use that data later once you figure
out what data set is important for you
to have intelligent decision-making with
machine learning and machine learning is
infrastructure demanding so with cloud
you can actually fix that problem and
then that sweet story of studio
requirements so if you're a Content
producer a Content distributor and you
work with multiple different Studios
each of them comes to you with a massive
contract of different requirements for
your infrastructure and if you work with
a cloud provider you really don't have
to worry about at least the basics of of
these requirements but all said and done
we still think hybrid solutions are
going to stay with me
industry for a while from now because
you have your transcoders encoders on
premise and you want to make sure that
you are keeping this infrastructure but
bursts into cloud whenever it's needed
and here we are we are in Google cloud
infrastructure when you look at that map
you really shouldn't see a lot of like
colorful dots and fibers even though
it's entertaining to look at it that way
too
but you should actually look at this as
a representation of six Google services
that have more than one billion
subscribers all these services are
sending traffic securely with a lot of
scalability through this network through
these points of presence and cloud is
using the very much the same
infrastructure that YouTube Gmail maps
and those services are are using over
the past three years we have spent 200
billion dollars on infrastructure to
maintain and expand our network we have
invested in 13 subsea cables we've
launched in 18 different regions 55
zones 134 network edges and 90 CDN
locations plus seventy three
interconnect locations we recently
launched in Switzerland and we are
launching in Indonesia and in Japan for
the second time but we know success
doesn't come from wealth what made
Google Google is technology so if you
look at different layers of technology
here you see we build our own chips we
build our own heart where we build our
own data centers we maintain it we
invent it kubernetes all of our services
across the board use kubernetes to scale
fast and and easily we have multiple
layers of identity to control access to
our platform if you look at how much
content is being stored and uploaded in
YouTube you will see storage is none of
it's not an issue that we would worry
about and and the security around it
either we talked about our backbone but
it's sitting on top of everything else
and the operational and security of
devices is something that our sarees are
paying attention to every day okay so
how would your service look like
ultimately if you're a visual kind of
visual studio company and you have
people sitting in Los Angeles in London
different parts of world you have
contents stored in multiple locations
you want to make sure that you can do
your editing on the device that is not
present in your data center but gives
you the illusion of having it at your
vicinity if you are a live sports
company like Jeff is you basically want
to make sure that your content is being
distributed around the world without any
delay if you are a telco and you've
acquired other telcos and you're
distributing to multiple locations you
want to make sure that your studio
rights are being being obeyed basically
and finally when you look at the amount
of storage you will be needing you
really don't want to worry about how
much content is being stored every day
so with Google Cloud we're giving you a
huge amount of infrastructure to scale
your services we give you containers
kubernetes app deployment services where
you can't deploy with a lot of
scalability and reach your goals we give
you a an 11-9 durable storage different
classes but instant access across the
board to to store your content your
network is basically a global network
that is well connected with our fiber
and your services are going to be
distributed in different Virtual Private
Networks but because that they're within
Google infrastructure there's security
is complied and the content is being
encrypted at rest Internet transit we
also give you a lot of big data and
machine learning capabilities to sit on
top of your services to give you
intelligent ideas about how you can push
for better business decisions and for
maintaining your customers on your
platform
this picture always cracks me up in 2010
this picture went online and it drove
the whole internet crazy about whether
it was Tom Hanks or Bill Murray yeah
what are you thinking thank you yes it's
Bill Murray the whole point is with the
whole hype about cloud these days
there's so much similarity between cloud
platforms that people sometimes get
confused about what would be the best
decision for for their own business idea
and we think there are certain things in
Google cloud that shines among all other
services we are investing a lot on
hybrid approaches cloud storage is a
very special service especially when it
comes to media we give you a metadata
caching redundancy duplication across
the board
it's multi-regional and regardless of
what class of the stories you put your
content on it's always instant
accessibility our sidin is very easy to
configure so it's literally just putting
a tick in a box and then content gets
cached everywhere we have a new approach
to machine learning we use Auto ml which
gives you access to our models but you
can train it with your own data so you
can get rid of a lot of you know
unnecessary labels that you would get
from it from a generic model and the
network that we talked about several
times it helps you distribute your
content a lot faster 20:18 it was
interesting for us we launched in 8 new
regions and we took dedicated and
partner interconnect to general
availability with rendering we rewrote
the whole thing platform and it's
available on Google infrastructure and
provides up to 48,000 cores to to
editors an individual editor we released
a live machine learning service for
video analysis in real time we released
a lot of features for metadata
enrichment and also for monetization
like video auto
object tracking and stuff like that in
terms of OTT ambato witches are into em
platform launched in Europe and our CDN
in terms of media when done GA and cloud
armor was launched to protect your
service and we are doing a lot of
interesting stuff with archiving so tape
digitization as a part of bigger Google
services and art and culture helps our
customers that have valuable content to
digitize those tapes with very little
money and then use machine learning to
enrich the metadata for those assets and
what's coming in 2019 we are launching
five new sea cables across the board
hybrid platforms are going to stay as
our highest priority this year so that
will help you work with your streaming
services your different types of if you
have machine learning stuff on premise
and a lot of different aspects of hybrid
workflows or in different cloud
providers with one control plane and the
same set of api's that are basically
industry standards like like kubernetes
for example we are replacing our MPAA
licensing with TPN which covers a lot
more broadcasters and content owners
that will be available on major TCP
infrastructure and we are doing a lot of
CDN enhancements we are working on
providing media API s for encoding
transcoding and ad insertion we are
releasing a neutral rendering platform
called open cue that's independent of
any specific software like zinc and we
are working on other AI services to go
to general availability and something
very interesting is about HTTP use that
you will be able to download the model
on a device offline and the device will
do the analysis and send the results to
the cloud so with that I'm going to ask
Jeff to come up the stage and take us to
their interesting story which is very
inspirational gonna talk over the next
Minister so about slice sports in in the
cloud we've been doing it for a long
time on premise and there's lots of
opportunities in the cloud so my name is
Jeff Webb I'm principal streaming
architects home from Sky UK hence the
accent I was so over what I'm going to
talk about is about sky so if those not
familiar with who we are can will clear
through that and believe in better
streaming which can kind of like as part
of our ethos success formula for lives
like delivering a live streaming service
so what does that make software-defined
streaming this is our concept for the
next generation platform how cloud
benefits and comparison or on-premise we
have a thing called single channel fault
domain which is really the kind of where
the key innovation comes in and I'm
going to show you what happens when
something goes wrong
so about sky we have twenty three point
six million customers in Europe and we
operate in seven European countries
we're very proud now to be part of the
Comcast family I'm sorry cause if she
went through a few months ago sky queue
which is our set-top-box proposition in
Europe and that's in five point five
million homes that's up from 3.4 million
last just last year we're increasing
investment in original drama of twenty
five percent increase over last year and
very interestingly if you produce really
good don't drama then more customers
will watch it so you can see viewing as
more than doubled in last three years
put this up here because this is
something else that as well I'm I'm
really proud to be part of a socially
responsible company so we have things
like sky ocean rescue and yeah you might
have seen things across the internet
things about you know it's trying to
save the oceans lose a lot of plastic
you know that that we throw away and
ends up in the animals and the whales
and things and it's not a good thing so
believing better streaming okay gonna
take you a little through a little
journey over the last 10 years I myself
being at Sky for 14 years I've been in
streaming team since 2009 and so over
that 10-year period we've gone through
three different generations we started
off as most broadcasters did in 2009
when Apple announced the HLS spec and we
wanted to be able to do live sports from
Premier League and things and so we did
what most Brussels broadcasters did they
went to went
t'market went did a comparison to go
through the RFI of P process bought some
black boxes plugged them in in de center
you had video in on one side you had
video outs on the other side and
customers were happy fast forward
several years business changes customers
want higher quality you've gone from
like standard definition phones now
you've got retina displays and you're on
your phones in your tabloid tablets and
so customers are expecting to get a
better quality obviously you've also got
big-screen Smart TVs and so on so we
went to generation two problem with the
first model is is that you go and and
you try and buy the biggest box you can
afford because you want to put maximize
your channel density so you put like
five channels on this big box in this
book this box cost you like twenty
thousand dollars if you want to get more
then you spend more that business model
is fine up until you have to go replace
it so every few years year you know
everybody every three years or so you
have to go through the upgrade refresh
cycle and that's very expensive way of
doing it
in reality as broadcast all you need is
the software ok the software that is the
intellectual property so that's what you
that's what we did in generation 2 we
said ok why would I buy your server ok I
just want to rent your software we can
run our own server as most enterprises
do we were in VMware so that's what we
did we virtualized it and we've run that
platform for six years now and that's
been very successful what I'm talking
today about is moving to the cloud
specifically for sports because there's
a really great opportunity for that ok
so just to give you some context what is
the success formula for delivering a
live streaming service this can be
sports it can be anything well firstly
it starts with content leaving aside the
technology customers I or in the pay TV
operator they want to be entertained
they want to watch the sports they want
to watch the Game of Thrones next week
they want to watch Italian or German
football and so on that is what they pay
for that's part of the experience and so
we shouldn't forget that at Sky I'm part
of what's called software engineering
software engineering is it's actually
quite a lot of people I mean in the
building I'm in there's like 800 or so
that are in software engineering and
these guys and girls are very clever and
they basically go and write the software
now unlike a lot of a lot of
and people we give this off away for
free so the network is obviously key to
this so if you own and operate your euro
Network and then obviously you can
ensure that that last mile connection
especially and is obviously optimized in
the UK we offer sky broadband which is a
our second largest ice broadband
provider in the UK this isn't I thinks
about six million customers Sky
broadband is also rolling out in scale
Italy later this year obviously have
lots of CD ends because you know we have
lots of traffic and lots of customers
which segues nicely onto customers so
here's a is what skq box looks like we
have now TVs that uses Roku and
obviously the mobile devices Smart TVs
consoles and so on ultimately if you
take content Plus developers Plus
network Plus this cost customers it all
gives you quality ok because lots of
customers they'll want to do the thing
what's the content at the same time so
next Monday is a good example you'll
have Game of Thrones on there at 9:00
p.m. it's going to be similar cast
between the you between US and Europe
customers want to watch it on their
devices do you want to watch it together
because it's a social experience just
like when you get you know Super Bowl or
Olympics and things and they want to
watch it in HD because that's what they
want that's what they want
okay so Software Defined streaming this
is reimagining of how we delivering it
we kind of came up with this it's a sort
of interesting concept called streaming
DevOps because we've been doing
streaming for ten years when we've been
doing very well and obviously customers
are happy with that but we wanted to
make it better and so we you know it's
been part of software engineering we
kind of looked and and asked our
colleagues and said ok how can we take
what other teams within Skye are doing
from the DevOps world and bring that
into streaming so we created something
we made it up it's called streaming
DevOps and really it's four things that
come into it first is around resilience
so as a broadcaster you're giving the
customer the experience in life sports
you can't afford to have downtime
because if they've missed the goal it's
not going to come again they're going to
have to watch on the replay on the
repeat or something so you want to try
and avoid that at all cost we came up
with a single channel fault two main
concept
I'll show you what that is in a couple
of slides and also I'll talk a give you
an example of how its self-healing so
basically if you have a problem don't
show the customer hide the problem until
you've resolved it okay so my channels
must stay on and that's critical
geographic resilience is very key
because you know example analogy will be
if you've got one data center don't put
all your channels in one data center
because chances are one day something
will go wrong and you'll lose not just
one channel but a whole bunch of
channels so have two baskets do exactly
the same
make sure the basket is right entacle
with your channels and you'll be a lot
better in order to do that you need
highly available synchronized video
streaming and that's what we'll we'll
show a little bit later the second
pillar is around speed to market okay
Malika touched on it earlier problem
with enterprises is that you have to go
through the procurement cycle preorder a
server today six to eight weeks later
the server will arrive they'll get
plugged in it's too long yeah you how
many football match is how many you know
basketball games have you missed it by
then and we'll quite a lot especially if
it's March Madness automated pipeline so
taking some of the benefits of what's
going on in DevOps so the continuous
integration continuous deployment
I'm sure obviously a lot of you if you
know Gulas and other people don't need
to explain what that is third pillar is
observability okay we're we're dealing
with video or a TV company so when that
game of thrones episode is coming
through you want to make sure that
before it gets to the customer that it's
actually good video and good audio
coming out because if you had a lip sync
issue it's a bad customer experience
okay so you want to make sure that
you're monitoring systems before you
actually get it to the customer is
actually good and doing that in an
automated way is is it the way to go
obviously for operations reasons you
want to be able to have centralized
logging and monitoring you using open
source tools like the old stack and also
real-time dashboards things like using
Ravana and Prometheus as well so you can
give Ops guys actually what's going on
right now with customers you know and
see how the platform is performing and
the fourth one really is actually the
key one and the reason why I'm here
today is talking about transportability
we at the outset we had a
a desire principle to make the platform
agnostic so on premise we run in VMware
C now we're taking it into Google TCP
okay just to mention though about cheeky
well not gingky on premise but I just
heard announcement yesterday that it's
coming so okay so how does the cloud
benefits life sports streaming okay
fairly obvious one it shortens the
development cycle because you now have
to wait fits of infrastructure we can
spin up now channels in minutes okay so
everything's pre-configured so if you
take a Formula One example those Grand
Prix's aren't on average about every two
weeks sometimes every other week
depending on the geography but sometimes
it's a bit longer but they have though
on Friday they have the practice
Saturday you have qualifying on Sunday
of the race each of those channels must
be consistently built so if I have the
Australian Grand Prix and then I two
weeks later I have the Singapore Grand
Prix and then a week later after Bahrain
Grand Prix then the actual channel is
configuration itself is the same the
only thing that's really changed over
there's three events is the time and
actually the content itself the way that
I deliver it to a client is is still the
same endpoint so when the customers
presses play it's still the same each
channel in this in the configuration
must be built consistently and we have a
yellow fell and yet another markup
language it has all the configuration
parameters for channels so you would
have things like your [ __ ] ladder
you'd have D runtimes you'd have stream
formats and so on this is really
critical because this allows you to main
state maintain or become stateless so
your channel configuration can be
stateless this is for this is very Pro
necessary for reasons of continues at
the moment we wanted to platform to be
modular so was he technology changes
from time to time you know some smart
people will go and invent new codecs and
things you know for new devices and
stuff you know things will come along
and things will go away so you needed to
be modular so that you not sort of
locked into a particular technology when
something much better can come along and
possibly even be cheaper as well
I'm cost-effective I was obviously you
know make it make sure that you can do
it cost basically speed to market fairly
obvious end-to-end automation pipeline
you do everything automatically do not
have engineers going into graphical user
interfaces manually putting a good four
iterations and pressing pressing apply
you know that we used to do that not
doing that anymore so increased
reliability in protection a single
channel folder me I'll show you that and
a really interesting thing that week
will now able to do in the cloud because
it's much more cost-effective is around
a be multivariate testing so imagine
being able to have a Sky Sports channel
let's say it's Formula one so that's on
the next slide and then you have the
standard version then what we have is a
sort of a b version of it which is
slightly different so you make the B
version of L to some customers use try
what it is in the real world and UK you
get feedback on it you know let you
would do going through a trance process
this is video so you actually you
actually need to see it you know you
need the data yeah
so it's quite key this new platform
allows us to maintain channel uptime so
that's really critical software upgrades
is you know classic problem ok so in
this diagram
I've taken a layered approach so my arms
not that big so at the top you've got
sky clients you've got sky go now TV Sky
Sports sky q okay on the next layer
we've got content delivery networks Oh
sue there's many of them we've got video
workflow with harmonic we've got court
services layer so this is a sort of
wrapper and we'll see that on the next
slide we're using Jenkins the sort
ketchup bottle inside what we call
source sources are configuration
management tool that we've written in
the house we're using Prometheus we've
got graph owner we've got puppet for
orchestration we've got L stack for
logging and information we've got
container and orchestration with docker
engine and kubernetes we do run around
communities cluster we're not using GK
at the moment and really what I would
call I is the only difference is the
bottom bit Lawton layer so you've got
on-premise infrastructure your typical
Intel Xeon you know processes etc that
cost you a lot of money and you know
generally go out to date pretty quickly
because you know the upgrade cycle on
servers is pretty fast in 12 to 18
months
and then on the bottom layer on the
right side you've got a bunch of cloud
stuff and Sui being here so we'll go
through we've got Google compute engine
which we're using we've got Google Cloud
Storage Google load balancing cloud
Rooter because we're dealing with video
we need to reliably get the video to the
cloud not trusting the internet could
use Internet you know that's possible
but you want to you want to take a sort
of more reliable approach to it so using
like Google Direct Connect having
redundant 10 gig links delivering
multiple channels into the cloud is the
sensible way to go
you need firewalls there cuz you need to
protect your data and you've got Matan
into nto access management so to name
but a few
and really that's the only difference
there it's double bottom the
infrastructure so what does single
channel full domain look like ok so I've
got an example here with formula formula
1 channel so I think it's quite
absolutely appreciate it's a little bit
busy diagram so working through from the
top we have skysport
we have in the blue box at the top
though we've got SDS top layer it
manages life channel configuration
that's the animal files and stuff that I
was talking about before you know your 5
make your 4 make III make you two make
you won't make your half-baked you know
in UAB or later for customers your
protocols your HLS your smoothie - do
your own types and stuff because you're
baiting the operator and it also manages
capacity as well so you were an Inc we
were on our own communities cluster and
so we managed the capacity on it to make
sure that we have enough resources to be
able to deliver the video at the right
time in the right place it also manages
the the metrics as well so it's pulling
all that in and what it's doing is
aggregating the metrics from the whole
stack so this is everything basically
coming in from the left hand side to the
right hand side it's also also pulling
in the client side metrics as well so
you actually get an end-to-end view
which is really really cool for
operations people because generally they
often complain they don't have enough
information or they don't have the right
information
so trying to fix that and give them that
visibility is really key the purple box
on the left hand side it says STS video
quality
monitoring so its purpose is to monitor
monitor the output to limit of the
mezzanine so this is your input into
your transcoder and it's comparing the
other 10 ET sources coming comparing
against the output which is what the
customers are consuming so they might be
gaining 1080 output 720 thousand six so
on and so forth so this is really key
and I mentioned it earlier because you
want to make sure that you're putting
good video out yeah you know dropping
frames that you're not having light lip
sync issues for example okay so that's
quite critical and then you've got the
other green box though which is harmonic
content prep okay what I would call out
here is really you see a there's a gray
box in the middle that says availability
zone one day yeah and then it's
surrounded by a sort of it's a little
bit hard to make out on this big screen
here but there's four boxes that there's
transcode package and storage
there's encryption an origin server what
you'll notice is there's a little sort
of Google cloud in the middle a you know
as we've seen him malika's diagram
before a Google Cloud it's a lot bigger
than that but I couldn't fit you on the
screen and then below you've got
availability zone - okay really key is
that we're doing this this is highly
available streaming so in normal world
we're only just doing the top layer you
know and that's how that's how we've
been doing it for last 10 years so the
innovation really is come around being
able to do it in parallel so you've got
two parallel streams coming in so if you
work through the example from left hand
side you have mezzanine mezzanine apple
doing over the Google Direct Connect
though I talked about that's 10
gigabytes redundant coming from two
different datacenters going into a
transcoder at the transcoder you've got
this is either blue in the red hours
you're coming in and there's a black
arrow in between there transcoders this
is synchronization I show it in the
yellow box below where it says frame
accurate synchronization and frame a
Curie is actually key because if you
want to put advertising on here you need
to make sure that it's frame accurate
package and storage in formats do HLS
you smoothie - okay you need it to also
be synchronized there so you need to
have a protocol that basically says okay
you know I'm here I'm here I'm here I'm
here I'll you know make sure that it's
the same because otherwise on the right
hand side
where it says active active lives in
Christ content and then with a little
sort of globe there you can't do
something funky like go a z1 z2 az1
AZ - yeah because you notice those two
red arrows allows us to load balance
live content in concurrently ok and
actually I think Moore's gonna give you
a little demo of that later so here
we're actually seeing that we can use
both legs in parallel these are in two
different availability zone so what I
should say there is that they're in the
same region so if we deployed this let's
use the US example well west coast now
so he went to Google's region in u.s.
west coast and we deployed this here we
put it into what one AZ and a second AZ
so this means that if the AZ had an
issue then there is another one
available to provide customers so you've
got redundancy I both the sort of
datacenter live all here within the
availability zones but also a channel
level because going back to my early
example channel density was all around
how many channels can I fit into this
server here so if I buy it the most
expensive server you know usual
economics works out that I can get more
channels on it problem is is that the
fault domain of that channel is the
number of channels you can get so if you
can get five channels on it and that box
goes gets broken then five channels are
affected you have now an outage go back
to my example about software upgrades
software upgrades come here every few
months they might fix bugs they might
introduce features but when it happens
you're going to take out five channels
yeah and this then this happens quite a
lot I'm so trying trying to avoid that
okay so on my next slide just talking
about I've just talked previously about
happy path when everything's working
great so what happens when something
goes wrong because you know we can't
assume that everything's great I've got
something's gone red here this is in
availability zone one my packager has
gone wrong I do
I don't really know foods just purposes
this example why that's happened right
don't really care actually what I care
about is the customer experience so the
customers on the excuse me on the right
hand side must carry on working they
must keep on serving the CDN
they must keep
the custard claims buffer on that on the
on the playback and it must be
consistent so don't interrupt that
customer experience so the way that you
go about this in this example is you
need to two things happen firstly is
that you need to detect those a fault
okay so in the bottom box here the
package area in a z1 has failed and so
this means a loss of resilience not a
loss of channel okay and that's big
distinction because you're still on a
you still making money and you're not
going and getting customer tickets
customers not going to have caught you
know call the call center to say hey
I've just noticed you had a loss a
result resilient because they can still
watch Game of Thrones or the football or
something so the second thing you need
to do on the right hand side is you see
there's a red X there where the
previously was an arrow you need to be a
make sure that you stop sending traffic
to the broken leg
so in here my example in availabilities
don't want that like is gone it's
basically it's it's not it's not
updating so the manifest is not updating
there's no fresh video because the
packager is no longer outputting video
so therefore it can't be encrypted
therefore it can't be delivered by
origin server and go back to my example
a z1 bad is he too good that's that
model doesn't work you know it's a bad
customer experience what you need to do
is make sure that you're only going to a
c2 so it's a z2 h z2 h z2 h z2 because
the other leg is fine it's operationally
good okay now the way that we've solved
this problem is we communities will do
obviously the monitoring it will detect
and rebuild that the package or in a z1
has failed a go refer you back to what I
was talking about a few minutes ago with
the animal fails the animal fails or the
state of the state of the foul of the
channel so then this guy sports one
example we can return it back to how it
was 30 minutes ago before the fault
occurred so we don't know why it's
happened what we weren't trying to do is
restore that service as quickly as we
can and put it back to how it was 30
minutes ago once we've done that and the
health checks pass channel resilience is
restore
okay we actually go back to the previous
slide where it's now an easy one it's
actually working again and that's
obviously really cool I'll just call out
the bottom things on the encryption
there's a pay TV operator we have
digital rights management so the the
things like PlayReady wide behind other
drm is etc and origin obviously storing
out and encrypted the tools that we used
to do this to actually restore recover
service obviously we operate our own
communities cluster in the two ACS we
have independent clusters so the one in
AC one is independent would have AZ two
so we run them in parallel and we're
doing the same work load in parallel
twice we using source source is
something that we wrote herself which is
our configuration management tool and it
basically goes and manages that so we
use and obviously things like to get
repos and when an engineer wants to make
changes for example you have to check in
there check out we've got version
control on it as well so and I don't
have a slide on it but we actually go
through - from a confidence point of
view we actually go through five
different lab five different realms on
our path production we go through a
development cycle so we have a
development environment we go through a
test environment we go through
non-functional test environment or we're
injecting load and we go through a stage
which is all about so testing and making
sure that it's reliable and because it's
very important video you know it's no
good if it stays up for 24 hours and
falls over you needed to run for two
weeks and then obviously in production
shows these what you doing the one of
the things that I will just sort of
finish on is when we talked about Sky
Sports about this and we went through
these sort of economics of the cloud one
of the things that was called out was we
did the number crunching on it and they
had a system that they've had for
operational about eight years and when
we went through and said look that
hardware is no longer supported we can't
get spare parts because I get software
upgrades for it we need to go and
replace that so we came out and it was a
big number it was a high six figured
number when we went through them and
said look how often do you actually use
that system because you know the formula
ones only on you know once every other
week the footballs on several times a
week what do you do at this time of day
when there's no football on there's no
formula Juana
well he's just sat there okay well maybe
that's not the cost-effective way to do
it so we asked them how many hours of
programming do you have to announce me
about thousand hours of programming per
year for various events when we said
okay well surely there's got to be more
cost-effective way of doing it could we
consider it like an optics type thing
and move those workloads to the cloud
and so we did that and there is
significant savings I mean it's more
than there's less than half the cost and
it's more flexible and we don't have all
those kind of pain points that we talked
about before we don't have to worry
about infrastructure
you know that's Google's problem we
don't have to worry about storage for
example that's Google's problem load
balancing Google's problem you know part
of the there we go okay thank you I'm
over time hey hello everyone thank you
Jeff
thank you for a very interesting
presentation you get to enjoy another
accent I'm originally from Ireland and
I'm going to try and speak very slowly
because I've got a tendency when I'm
nervous in front of big crowds to speak
awfully quickly thank you very much so
I'm from harmonic and we believe in
smarter faster simpler of video
streaming and we were very excited to be
involved with Sky on Google on this
project just a little bit of background
on who harmonic are some of you may
never have heard of us although I'm sure
that over the years you've watched video
that's flowed through many of our
devices we've been around for over 20
years we are headquartered in Silicon
Valley have you happen to drive along
the 237 or about North first Street
around the world we have over 5,000
customers and the media and service
provider sector we started off building
appliances and if we look at the number
of over-the-top channels we have
deployed and we entered the streaming
market abite when Jeff did many years
ago we have 38,000 live channels
deployed today
most of those challenges channels are
deployed on appliances but many of them
are now I deployed in our software as a
service offering in fact if I look at
ourself or as a service offering for our
customers we actually deliver video from
our origin service to over 6.5 million
subscribers who pay those those
customers of ours every month for the
video services that they watch
subscription video is really difficult
as Jeff has described you have to
provide a really high quality of service
and our goal these days is really to
make sure that we maximize that quality
of experience for our customers
customers so how did we do that how did
we make the transition from what was
effectively a box manufacturer in
Silicon Valley to someone who provides
software as a service offering it was no
small change but as the product
architect it was my job six years ago to
pick off a project that looked at
everything harmonic did for its
customers from end to end and to think
about how we could reinvest that from
hardware
delivery to a software delivery for
customers we take care of many things we
take care of ingesting content we take
care of play out graphics transcoding
over-the-top even into the traditional
cable world and satellite world we
provide statistical multiplexing
solutions we encrypt the content we
package it we provide origin serving
functionality manifest manipulation
unmounting and there was a very
traditional way of delivering that in
the appliance world very simple in terms
of boxes delivering functionality
everybody understood exactly how it was
deployed what we needed to do was we
needed to think about it reinvent it and
reinvent it and deliver something that
has a different architecture it's based
on containers and think about all of
those problems that you have described
how do you effectively provide one for
one resilience how do you provide
upgradeable update and we did that in
a product that we did we described we
called vos which is our cloud native
media processing platform and is what
Jeff used and we also deliver that as a
SAS offering vos 362 our customers you
know when I look at sky sky gave me all
of the usual requirements that anyone
starts off with a life project they
really wanted to hit all of the devices
they needed to use all of the streaming
formats to make sure they got into those
devices closed captioning they need x
metadata because they were doing sports
you want to be able to know that the
goals gone off send notifications and
they really want that ease of
installation ease of monitoring in Egypt
ease of recovery these what this is what
I hear from every customer but what was
different about Sky's requirements was
that desire to make it better that no
single point of failure and although
Jeff didn't mention it he also put a
second constraint on it which was he
didn't want any additional delay to his
sports because you know what we could
have built a very really very very
redundant system but if we had delayed
another 30 seconds but he said no don't
want any more delay to my sports they
need to be faster not slower so that
would that made it a little bit harder I
think we've been 45 minutes into this
presentation and it's time you saw some
video but before I do I'm just going to
show you one diagram this is the diagram
of the video that I'm gonna show you how
we put it together we deployed out in
Google Clyde we went a little bit
farther than Jeff asked for we put it in
separate in separate zones not just
separate availability zones and we used
gke
not GCP because you know what I like it
when Google deploys kubernetes for me
like Jeff said I don't want to worry
about that either we built this system
let's what let's see what that eight be
switching looks like from a customer
standpoint okay so here's some beautiful
content and while you watch the
beautiful content and does say it's in
4k and HDR and although I'm standing and
it's in a theater today I'm really sorry
to tell you what you're watching isn't
in 4k and HDR I wish that it was
um however if at home you would love to
see it and you happen to have a Roku
streaming device there is a nasa channel
and on the Roku streaming device that we
provide the backend for that will allow
you to see the same content in 4k and
HDR and breathtaking as the content is
here it's even more breathtaking there
while you've been watching the video
perhaps you've noticed the vos 360 logo
popping back and forth from the left and
right to the screen that wasn't put
there by a professional that was put
there by me which is why it's so
accurately positioned so what I did
actually was I went into my I went into
those two transcoding instances that I
showed you previously and I can figure
out one of them to put the logo on the
left side and the other one to put the
logo on the right side a little bit of a
difference and so that's why you get to
see it popping back and forward from
either side but it is beautiful content
and I do encourage you to go and have a
look at it I'm a great believer in in
NASA I love it and I love the content
they produce some of the the moon rises
are amazing to watch we did go even
farther than just own one and Zone two
we offer ourselves we're not just as a
SAS I told you we so let the customers
on premise so here is another diagram
where you could actually do that same
synchronization with an on premise
cluster and a cluster in GCP or GK I
think we actually did deliver on what
sky wanted and the challenge that we
really had to solve with this challenge
called the cap theorem a Brewers theorem
for the computer scientists among you we
already know what it is for those of us
who don't understand basically if we
partition two things and we drop
information between them
then we have to make a decision about
whether or not we we serve every request
and sometimes the requests are different
or we only serve requests from one side
when we know there are problems we don't
want the video to jump back and forward
it gotta look seamless like it did here
so we sacrifice and availability and the
whole challenge was to make your
availability numbers for that backup
system as high as possible
that delivers gay benefits it give them
me and free proof Falls tolerance it
give him the ability to do green-blue
upgrades it give them the ability to do
a/b testing way more than we originally
thought of when we started off looking
at the fault tolerance of this project
you know I think as harmonic in this
project we really did deliver smarter
faster simpler video streaming and you
know if it's working with customers like
Skye and working with people like Google
that enables us to deliver on some of
the the most fantastic projects in the
world with some of the greatest content
formula one NASA it's a great place to
be Malika do you have a question for
both of us or are we out of time all
right well I don't get answer our
question thank you very much indeed
Thank You Malika thank you Jeff it's
been great to be here I hope you enjoyed
it
[Applause]
[Music]